Robert did you quit your job and then
make sex and sushi how did that all work
out it was that's pretty much how it
worked up I was just like I'm done I
initially i think it was i'm going to
take a leave of absence kind of thing i
was running a hedge fund at that point
so it wasn't like I was working for some
entity so I just basically shut it down
and it was I returned investors money
and so forth and initially it was sort
of like let me just take six months off
and see what happens kind of thing and
it became you know more than six months
it's still going but yeah I just shut
everything down yeah right and so you
initially had a DP attach the project
what happened with that you gonna act in
it you wrote it right you had someone
you knew starring in at a female lead I
had to shed no well my girlfriend at the
time played my secretary and the the
opposite lead I I just met through
casting oh great yeah but the DP story
is yes so I I didn't have any experience
making a movie and so I figured let me
hire a pro DP who knows what the hell
he's doing and I did that and and we
shot for 34 days or something and um I
mean just the first shot I was told by
him that typically the first days of
disaster anyway but I don't know that
that's true but it took him like four
hours to set up this really basic shot
and I was like I guess this is how they
do it what do I know I'd never been on a
set before and after a few days of this
kind of stuff where it has to be this
way and the lighting and the crew and
everything I was like wait a minute you
know even if it does have to be like
this like I'm not comfortable with this
I'm running the show you're not running
it and we had you know he had a bit of
an ego and I do as well and so we
clashed and I said what about if we just
she now sorted and he was like no no no
so I said finally I just I said you're
done you're
goodbye and the takeaway for me for that
was if this thing's going to get
up somehow if it's going to look shitty
you if there's going to be something
wrong with it I want to be because I
trusted my instincts and I was wrong
rather than I didn't trust my instincts
and I just let this guy do whatever the
he wanted and you know and I think
there's something to that in terms of
the shooting the spirit of the shooting
really changed the vibe really changed
on the set because it was just kind of
like not like a punk rock kind of vibe
but it wasn't so you know we're curing
cancer kind of thing and it's got to be
this dogmatic sort of that you know
and addition to which we were making you
know a thirty thousand dollar romantic
comedy it wasn't like we were you know
some serious period piece and heavy
drama in that so so yeah I just I
just shot the thing myself and the
credit the IMDb credit is Walter brute
which is an anagram of Robert lon my
name yeah and you funded the film
yourself right right okay are you
forgive me if this is too personal bar
are you putting this on a credit card
how are you funing the film where the
benefits of wall street is you know your
credit cards don't get maxed out
everyone seriously so yeah I had my
right you have money and were there
times when you felt like oh this is a
runaway train or once you kind of took
the helm and the DP was out you felt
like this is fun this is nice it's a
good question yeah you know it's funny I
said this at the time and I repeat it
today the IE I wrote it I directed it I
acted it and I DP did I whatever and I
also produced it and if I just had to
produce it I still wouldn't want to do
it like producing for me I it was I
didn't like it why because you're you
know it's the kind of stuff that I like
doing the creative and the acting
and all of that stuff and like what's in
the frame and making a movie but they're
getting a location set up and making
sure this person shows up and like that
is a disaster I'd much rather
let you know pay somebody else to do it
I just don't have the temperament for it
in addition to which I almost maybe have
too much of a tempering before because
as a director I'm
I am I micromanage everything you know
so if anything's going wrong in terms of
the ancillary stuff the producer stuff
like that's all think about and it
becomes I get very stressed about it so
thou that was that sucked I hated that
yeah
you